hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the last part of
slender the arrival ok we are on the
last stage I checked I checked by just
clicking the button to get into this
level but I checked nonetheless so we
are about to have our final
confrontation with mr. Slendy and any of
his proxies that yet remain the house
had to go it can't save me anymore
alrighty then
so some about a house I gotta get to the
radio tower I'm guessing for some magic
anti Slendy thing don't know what don't
know why don't question anything just
keep moving forward alright ciao rip
what do we get meet me by the street in
an hour
I left a lift of things to bring with
you leave everything else behind I'll
explain everything as soon as I see you
I know how to fix all of this don't tell
Lauren about me see ah who the hell is
CR anyway I do not know but I will find
out soon enough
hahahaha you're helping his arrival and
this um hahahaha I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry for everything this isn't your
fault I did this by the time you read
this it's already too late for you
don't let him into any more lives this
was all my fault this gonna end with you
I let him in why did I ever let him in
I'm so sorry for placing this burden on
you I wish it was all on me
this can't spread any further please it
all has to end with you I wish to some
other way it has to end
God forgive me ok
God can't help you now you got Slendy up
your butt you let her in should not have
let him in especially up your foot
that's just wrong
Oh shits on fire yo ah I saw him and he
was tentacley he had ten - uh-oh not
that way
he had a great many tentacles of which I
saw I'm pretty sure he wants to do
something with me with them
ah fire no I'm guessing I gotta get to
the radio tower don't know how
everything caught fire but where is he I
don't even see him I don't even slider I
don't have time to message you I gotta
help
let you in to me or something I don't
really know he's close whatever it
wherever he is ah fine oh that didn't
hurt or anything
ah I'm doing a final sprint up the
mountain I got legs of Steel by Mabel
now
what where was he he wasn't even close
to me what are you talking about he was
like a mile away
I wasn't in and near me
screw that go away Slendy that's stupid
it wasn't even near me I must have gone
some wrong way I didn't get there quick
enough or something I took an indirect
route either way let's get this done
I'm hoping to not run into any more bugs
oh here we hope
okay I must be doing a lot better
because I'm a lot closer and I still
haven't seen any sort of the static ease
yeah ow ow ow ow ow ow ow all right
doing better doing better doing good
doing good
like I said legs of Steel okay Shaboom
all right what am I looking for now I'm
almost out of camera battery I do not
know what I'm looking for door needs a
key I'm looking for a key to that door
was there anything in here I don't think
so I better hurry because slanty is
banging on the door where's the damn key
where's the damn key open up your [ __ ]
there it is
running running open up open the damn
door you [ __ ]
sorry I don't mean to call you [ __ ] I
don't mean that your flashlight is dead
who killed it oh lordy somebody I don't
have time to read that okay I've done to
read this now cuz I can't oh hello
she
okay Oh
Oh
ah there was nothing nothing good
nothing there's nothing that was not
good that was not good at all ha ha ha
ha ha ha Oh kind of ending with that
okay let me try to piece together some
of the logic so far I'm guessing that
body was the burnt body of whoever CR
was he was trying regionally to try to
stop Slenderman but eventually down the
road realized that he couldn't there was
literally no way to stop him only to
stop him from spreading his arrival had
already come and gone this chapter was
named a rival the last one this is just
all me guessing by the way I don't
really know this is what I'm piecing
together from the story but anyway
saina man had already arrived because
obviously was there in haunting him the
the character that we were playing I
believe was there were two girls
original there was two girls there was
one mom and two girls and then this CR
person I don't know who TR was because
he wasn't involved in the flashback at
all originally or there was just the
girl in the way the girl in the video
that in the house which got thrown out
the window I'm not sure who that was but
I think her story ended earlier she was
the one that was being haunted on
earlier there was girl named Laura I'm
not sure but like it's really convoluted
I'm not exactly sure what goes where
because I just can't I'm like going his
circles a story to make sense but anyway
the ending from what I can guess
happened is that I was I was being led
to believe where my character was going
that there was a way to stop him just
like CR did but um the only way to stop
Sunday from doing something was to burn
the whole forest down I I don't know in
a vain attempt to try to stop sediment
but he didn't seem to be that affected
by fire so I got trapped in a dead-end
the same place at CR was left saying
that he failed obviously and then I
meant the same horrific and now I don't
know if the character that we're playing
now is the same character that was
finding the pages in the first one
in the woods or if um that was a
different character and me finding the
pages in the woods elsewhere in this
game was like my initiation into the
same loop the same way that Slenderman
gets in your mind it makes you go crazy
either way
Slenderman obviously got in deep way
early on I don't even know why I came
into these woods but in the first place
I think I might even be an outside party
but I don't know it's just all so weird
I don't know failed positive temps I
don't know what that means
there are 26 items are you kidding me
I missed um 8c uh I don't know I don't
think there's anything here that I found
19 of 26 items I finished everything I
finished the arrival in 47 seconds I'll
think so well wait a minute now I'm not
so sure and I just punched my microphone
ow
but anyway I don't see anything else
here for making cool stuff happen but
I'm guessing that maybe if you played it
on hardcore there might be something
else to the ending so let me know if
that's worth it because I might want to
do a hardcore playthrough so but anyway
for now that is slender the arrival for
a $10 game that's only like barely an
hour long it's hard to justify I like to
justify games on whether they're worth
the money now this had a lot of you know
hype for it there was a lot of buildup
for this game and I can't say that I was
disappointed in it but cuz it was really
interesting what they put I mean totally
confusing I had no idea what's going on
the entire way some of the mechanics
were iffy there were a lot of bugs that
I ran into but I'm guessing the average
person wouldn't run into that many
but there just wasn't a lot there I
expected there to be so much more for
what it is but at the same time me being
a big supporter of
okay me being a big supporter of the
indie gaming community I would gladly
pay more for that but I think in the end
it's still worth the $10 that it is it
was a great game it was definitely
worthy of being a slender title they did
a great job with this I'm I'm pretty
happy with the way it turned out just
the atmosphere was so dripping with
slenderness um III don't know if they
were planning to do more with like no I
don't know if that was masking people
are still not sure if that was or was
not mask II but anyway I was hoping that
they were gonna do more but at the end
I'm still not disappointed that's pretty
much to summon of all that I'm trying to
say here so take it for what you will I
would definitely recommend buying it
trying it for yourself let me know if
it's worth it doing a hardcore
playthrough I will see about that later
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more games and
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video
Oh
so